- We love being able to
end the show with something
extra positive.
This is what I'm liking.
♪ Upbeat music ♪
It's no secret I don't
keep up on much sports ball
but I will never deny that sports
can really bring people together.
Just look at this beautiful
video of a young boy
and his grandpa.
- [Grandpa] What did you do?
- So, you know, I got
two home runs, right?
- You got two, Jack.
- And then my grand slam.
I signed the ball for you.
- Okay.
- Is it dated?
- And it says
- No
- I'll put the date on it for you.
- And it says, Papa, I love you.
- (voice cracking) Why did you do that?
- Because you taught me
everything about baseball.
- Oh, honey.
That's so sweet.
I'll put it on my, I'll
put it right on my-
Oh God, that was so good.
Wow, honey. Woo!
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
If you're not crying right
now, there's something wrong
with your cold dead heart.
That is like the most
beautiful thing ever.
We have that young athlete on
the line along with his papa.
Let's say hi to Felix and
Bruce watching on KSFYF4.
Hi y'all.
How are y'all doing?
- (both) Hello.
It's so nice to meet you.
- [Kelly] Nice to meet you as well.
Oh my gosh, you're such
a beautiful young man.
So you, Bruce, you were clearly so touched
by Felix giving you one of his game balls.
That was amazing to watch.
- Yes. That was a special, special day.
I mean, he had such a great day.
Hits two home runs inside the park.
And still thinks about his
papa, comes over the house
gives me a ball, says, Papa, I love you.
Now, it doesn't get much
better than that, Kelly.
- Oh my gosh.
Yeah, you are,
your family is so beautiful.
Felix, your Papa's the one who
got you into baseball, right?
- Yeah. When I was three, I
started playing catch with him,
and then when I was four
I started playing T-ball,
which was fun,
and ever since then I've
been playing baseball
and now I'm on a traveling team with it,
which is really cool.
And my papa taught me how to pitch,
how to catch, how to catch pop flies.
And most importantly, he taught me
that it doesn't matter if
you win, lose, strike out,
don't catch a pop fly,
it just matters if you have fun.
Oh, and Kelly, do you wanna hear a joke
that my papa taught me?
- Yes, I do, I definitely do.
- How many home runs
has Kelly Clarkson hit?
- Oh, I don't know how many.
- Every time you're on
stage, you hit a home run.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
(audience cheering)
Oh my God,
you two.
I'm just like- you-
you have just made me feel so good.
Just this interview alone.
You too have so much light about you.
Thank you so much for sharing it with us.
Thank you Felix and Bruce, I'm
liking your post right now.
And that's not all,
our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of Friction,
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly
just like y'all,
so they're just gonna give
you a thousand dollars
for being you.
- Whoa.
- Whoa!
(Audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Oh my God, that's amazing.
I love you guys.
Have a blessed night
and thank you to all of our guests today.
Jessica Chastain, Ryan
Phillippe, Paria, Melody,
and Lawrence Zarian.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, try and change it.